this is really rare for me because
usually when i'm giving lessons i like
to be the one teaching gambits and
showing how to play dubiously
and then try and win quickly
and that's not to say maybe i can show
you some of the cooler stafford lines if
you ever have
inspiration to start playing gambits
yourself like stafford or otherwise
um because it's a great opening to play
against like really unprepared players
wait what's your favorite gambit like
stafford by far yeah by far okay then i
picked the right coach
i'm making you counter your own campaign
is what i'm trying to do here that's
true it's going to be difficult for me
i've never had a lesson like this where
i show
someone how to to play against the
stafford but the thing is i've played
hundreds if not thousands of games in
stafford so
i'll be able to give you maybe a few
different options and
and show what
gives me the most problems
because there's some certain players i
just don't play stafford against because
i know they're going to be preparing and
punish me
to the full extent
of course yeah that totally makes sense
i mean you
it's staffers and stuff like that and
gambits in general it should not like if
you already know you're gonna play
against somebody then
like if it's a match format or anything
like that you're just not gonna go for
it right so that makes a little sense
yes yeah it always depends on the
opponent though like some players you'll
see like they don't have much experience
or they might play the line that's
sub-optimal
um
i think we played
i play i get it but when we played our
previous matches like i saw you you go
into this line
where like it it looks solid have your
kids hide your wife eric out here
refuting his own
i think you you probably remember going
into this right
i do but it ends up being a big mess
yeah it's actually one of like the
cooler traps of the stafford where
mm-hmm
it's not something you want to repeat
again or even a lot of knight takes h2
i've learned that this h3 move at some
point is very important
so one of the things with white playing
against the stafford
is move order
move order is sometimes the trickiest
thing because if you play like one thing
out of order it can allow black like so
much fun
and i guess we can start with like a
general rapporteur
like you're
in general against the petrov you're
taking on e5 from what i can see like
you don't you don't usually play knight
c3
um
because there's other moves that exist
here like there's pawn d4
which is another like very stable way of
playing against uh
against the petrov
um and actually completely avoids the
stafford too like if you just wanted to
avoid stafford completely you could play
d4
and enjoy life
i had no idea i i do like to play the
regular pet shop i always play with like
nine takes e5 and after d6 i play knight
to c4
i saw that yeah i was looking up your
games like right before we hopped on
call oh i saw you have a bunch of games
in this line which
i know is topical like during world
championship
yeah absolutely
a lot of preparation there but but yeah
so when you when you encounter
knight c6
then this is the start of stafford and
uh you should be taking on c6
some people decline it
which just gives black a slightly
preferable position
um
there's a move that i've been enjoying
playing recently and i'll i'll show this
to you
just if you want to play it for content
in the future
have you heard of the
have you heard of the halloween gambit
i have actually yes so halloween gambit
usually comes from a four nights
where
and then after knight c6 knight takes e5
knight takes a d4
exactly takes in d4 and white stacks a
piece for the the big pawn center
um
the thing is when you go into stafford
if you really wanted to be the gambiter
you could transpose into halloween by
playing knight c3
i'm not gonna give this to you as my
main recommendation i'm just going to
say it's possible
and if you just want to have fun and be
the one gamuting and and especially
around the season of halloween
it's a festive opening
yeah it's a festive opening okay for for
content we might try this opening on
stream at some point yes
okay
but yeah if if you want to like be
objectively
proper
and
play the best move take on c6
everyone takes back with deepon
and this is kind of the key starting
position in stafford
um
and when like preparing for this call i
was conflicted because there's actually
a lot of
like refutations to the stafford
and it's just a matter of
choosing one
and knowing it well
okay
uh so
i like d3 and so two three currently
okay
yeah so d3
if you have any other recommendations or
if you think that something's better
something might be better let's see what
you're playing currently and then then
maybe we'll we'll adjust we'll try and
fine-tune okay um so i'll play bishop c5
uh i will play h3
i'll take on f2
oh
oh dear
uh yes
so this is
this is like one of the reasons i really
like stafford
is because stuff like this you're trying
to play really safe
and already like you're you're walking
into really messy line
white's still okay here if you play king
g1 black can just force a draw
i think i lost like this against you at
some point in the match it's possible
yeah even like gm's will walk into this
a lot of people will play king f3
and then there's a funny line castling
king james e4
you don't really want to go into this as
white even though light's up two pieces
uh
king is on a bit of a trip
yeah it's it's fun when this happens
though and another reason why
i'm not kind of giving up this opening
this
significant number of players will walk
into this
okay um
if
there's a similar line where white can
try c3
i think it's good we're going through
like the the
move orders which don't quite work for
white just so you have the understanding
of like what black's tactical ideas are
um c3 is an attempt to just take over
the center which is generally what you
want to do against stafford like you
have the two center pawns
um this gets messy after knight takes e4
because you can't take back
which will allow bishop takes f2 and
you're losing a queen
in e2 there's bishop g4
tactics
and
this is still objectively good for white
i don't recommend going into it because
there's there's some compensation for
black but after this takes here
uh
f5
uh
yeah if you know it really well you'll
be okay as white but uh probably best to
avoid
okay um
can't do that
so
you don't want to play h3 you don't want
to play c3
black is threatening knight g4 here
which is probably why like a lot of
times you are liking to play bishop e3
but that also gives lack a lot of
initiative
so the move to play
yeah yeah so the move to play is bishop
e2
okay
this way you just prevent the knight
from coming in
um actually i shouldn't say prevent
because the g4 is actually still a
playable move
which we can get to
because you take this queen h4 i'm
guessing
so if takes queen h4 yeah
um
good news is it's still completely okay
for
for white
um
and there's actually a really thorough
video on youtube
by nerditsky
where he covers this recommendation he
actually spends a good
deal of time
covering this line
for white and just showing how to like
neutralize all the threats
um the main thing to know is don't get
mated
thanks
um and then put your queen on g3
got it
if you know just
up until this point you'll
you'll enjoy life a lot more even
compared to what you
have been playing already
nerdsy has like way more analysis from
this position
which we could get into
um but it's probably just worth watching
that video and uh
yeah
also keeping it simple enough so it's
quick shaq can understand because you
know
yeah i'm trying to give you like the
most like digestible lines that that
won't be too difficult to forget
yeah i do appreciate it
yeah and the the thing with this line is
most players don't play knight g4
most players actually play h5
oh so g4 is more of like a sideline you
won't encounter too often but as long as
you just remember take get your queen to
g3 you'll be fine
okay i can remember that awesome
so
let's say h5
right
and now
again black is preparing to play
knight g4
and this is where move order is again
pretty important
what would be your first kind of
impression here
[Music]
don't play h3
probably
i feel like playing h3 in these
positions always ends up being something
a little bit bad i'm always a little bit
scared i need stuff like h3 here h3 is
like a very safe looking move
yeah uh but you do
i'll say h3 is completely fine like
objectively it's still much better for
white the reason why i wouldn't
recommend h3 as like your main
white repertoire
is because things get a little bit messy
after queen d4
oh where
the pawn is attacked
you want to play bishop e3 but b2 is
also hanging
and then if you castle
there's
there is this move queen d6 to threaten
knight g4 and you really have to be
accurate and i don't think it's worth
trying to memorize
like many more moves of the the computer
refutation
um because there is
like i think more simple line to go for
i get that yeah but this is just part of
my preparation like if anyone
plays h3 i'm happy to go into queen d4
queen d6 and it's very effective in
blitz and bullet because a lot of white
players are just not prepared
so
instead of h3 this is where you can play
c3
preparing d4
and this is again what naraditsky like
shows in his video d4
allows you to just expand with tempo in
the center
and
uh there's not too many great ways for
black to deal with a threat
okay
the main move is knight g4 here and i
think this is the one we should focus on
okay i that looks very scary so i agree
uh-huh there's another move
bishop b6
which i used to play myself
huh well this move is to like just
prevent d4 from being a direct spread
yeah this is less threatening but it's
more prophylactic
yeah
um but this looks that this doesn't look
that difficult to deal with like what if
i just developed like knight to d2 or
yeah knight d2 i'll admit i actually
don't know like the
absolute precise move but knight d2
looks completely fine
if we turn on the engine here i'm sure
it's going to give like plus two for
white
oh wow
okay yeah it gives almost plus three
actually plus two points
five two point
and yeah i guess the thing to understand
is if black ever goes for knight g4
to target f2
then there's
first of all the reason why you played
knight d2 is to reinforce e4
yeah and you can just respond to knight
g4 with d4 just block the bishop
yep got it
so
yeah and it looks like most of the
engine lines like if bishop e6 top
engine move then you can play d4 and
you're gonna have a
happy stable center
nothing too wrong
and happy stable life
exactly
yep
so black is gonna try and make you
unhappy and unstable
with the move knight g4
okay
and
if i play anything like d4 now i'm
guessing it's
well if i play d4 no it's not totally
all right because yeah so this is where
things begin to get interesting
and there's there's a lot of like the
favorite gamut it's kind of like an
onion
there's a lot of layers
to keep peeling away
and sometimes it'll make you cry but
that's part of the learning process
that's an amazing line the stafford camp
is a bit like an onion sometimes they'll
make you cry
yeah yeah it's uh
but sometimes like if you cook it right
it'll taste really good
so anyway um knight g4
used to just not be a known move until
there was a this youtube video
um it was called something like the
magical stafford line
by jonathan trance um where he found a
line that was not covered in the
nereditsky refutation video oh god and
the idea is that after d4
it looks like everything is is happy for
for white
black and strike with queen h4
okay and i go g3 and you go g3 and i go
queen f6
uh
and i go
castle
is interesting
most people don't castle they don't uh
they're not uh
brave enough i think counseling is
actually a fine move it's completely
playable
lovely stafford streams um there are
so
it gets into a position where white is
objectively much better like if you turn
on the engine it will give almost plus
four i think
right
uh engine is actually giving plus five
oh my god what
now
can i just be an engine
the thing about
this position specifically
from a practical standpoint
like if you look up the games like over
the course of like what's been played on
chat.com and leeches black actually
scores reasonably well
because there's a lot of lines where
it's still easy to go wrong for whites
and things can get very messy
yep and even in this like jonathan
trance video he found a line like he
played black against stockfish
and almost managed to get a winning
position as black
that's crazy which is crazy given
stockfish just says it's completely
winning for whites
yeah so it's one of those openings yeah
and then one of the main ideas uh like
critical variations which i'll just show
you not something you need to remember
it's just to appreciate the beauty of
the line
is if white plays f3
looks like white is just winning
piece easy
then there's h4
and already okay some pressure along
each file
white can try and just keep all the
bases covered rook g1 but then after
takes
takes rook h2
[Music]
there's so many lines where like
things get messy and black's gonna get
compensation even if black is losing a
piece
and
there's some
there's some like really
insane engine line
stemming after this
black has this move
light doesn't want to take this and if
queen d4
or like a crazy engine move bishops e4
which like
it creates a situation engine will still
say white's winning but if you dig deep
it's like almost a draw
okay
and
this isn't worth getting into but it
just shows that
um these positions have a lot of there's
some spiciness yeah
yeah i had this a few months ago
actually in entitled tuesday against a
strong gm and bullet stop bishop c4
managed to win
like most of the game being opening crap
oh my god that's crazy i mean this is
the part where chess is such a
frustrating game sometimes because if
people are playing the stanford against
me they probably know how to play it and
i'm over here like i don't know what i'm
doing please go easy on me
so again you you just need to put in the
work of remembering kind of the key line
and
uh
acknowledging that these traps exist but
you're not gonna fall into the landmines
okay got it so just play chess right
just play chess but but commit at least
the first 10 moves to memory
just commit the first 10 moves to memory
it's kind of weird okay just remember
all the key lines yep i agree though i
do fully agree i know i'm laughing right
now but
i'm laughing in part because this is
exactly part of the reason why i stopped
playing competitive
it's like huh now i'm going back into it
because i've been getting frustrated
with online chess like how do we come
all the way back here
yeah so yeah sometimes um like at the
lower levels you can just play chess and
understand principles and stuff
but at
my level at like our level
opening preparation is a much larger
factor um
because people will be uh people are
just super well prepared these days
there's more tricks and traps which
are easy to especially when when you
play the same thing over and over again
you want to make sure your repertoire is
robust
so the line that i'll recommend for you
uh i was actually curious about castling
because i think this is actually a very
fine line like if you wanted to castle
you're completely fine here
engine will say like plus three it's
giving bishop f8 as the top move
which is a very good sign
yeah that doesn't seem like a good move
at all i mean i think part of the reason
that this position like this costly
thing would actually work is because if
you ever play h4 then bishop takes g4 so
that just shuts down most of blacks it's
hard for box to make progress like we
we've established this
uh threatening looking knight but it's
it's hard to actually
crack through and white has to move f3
here oops there's a mouse slip on f3
kicking away the knight
and
yeah top engine moves knight h6
so
yeah the thing to know here is
don't play f3 f3 is still probably a
fine move but it walks into a lot of
unnecessary complications yeah yeah i
fully agreed the move i was going to
initially recommend for you is bishop f4
or bishop f3
oh
is also like completely playable just uh
blocking the
uh the queen from targeting f2 this
bishop still attacked
at some point
you're going to be on your own
and as long as you you have some game
plan between bishop atherean castling
it's going to be hard for for black to
hurt you
with all this said i do have a few
traps like if you were to play bishop f3
there's still a few ways
that like can go wrong
so i guess i could show you
like the main trap i've been trying to
pull lately and sometimes it can work
quite effectively
is to blitz out the move bishop e6
uh
because if d takes c5
d takes c5 is zen met with i believe
rook d rook d yeah rook d8 first
natural move is queen e2
right and then there will be and then 95
oh knight to e5 and already black is
better yeah you get hit with the 93 next
move too yep
oh wow so that's the thing about this
line like there's
we're unpeeling more layers
this is why i think i'm gonna stick with
castle because i think castle is the
easiest you just kind of put your king
away and you follow the opening
principles and you know you gone into
your life
i think that's fair yeah i'll i'll admit
i haven't explored this line
so thoroughly so now now i feel
incentivized to study this line really
deeply and try and find some
some
tricks and traps against white castling
oh no oh no i was about to i was about
to be like yep i've solved the stafford
no more stings from eric i can just be
done with this for the rest of my life
but
but this is how chess works like
when you castle you know it's
objectively good for light it's it's
close to objectively winning
if
somehow you run into like some tricky
prep that you're gonna learn from it
um but you should know that okay the
position's much better for white there's
no reason to be too afraid
unless maybe i'm preparing for you very
deeply then i'm gonna try and find some
way to he's gonna he's gonna eric is
gonna pull out the onion and make you
cry make you peel away the layers of the
onion and then you will cry yeah i'm
gonna keep peeling away more layers but
uh
yeah castling counseling looks fine i
mean there's not too many openings where
you're gonna get like a plus
two almost plus three advantage by move
ten
yeah and this isn't too much to remember
i think the trickiest thing is to
remember the move order
with like when to play c3 when to play
bishop e2
so
maybe it's worth reviewing like real
quick
okay add a three number six
yeah
takes
takes
oh wait there's no nice e3 line here
right knight c3 is just bad
knight c3 is is completely fine oh it's
actually
there's a chess.com like premium video
course
where uh apparel she recommends like c3
oh this is the one that i was i kind of
confused i think it was the one with
bishop c5 and then i played h3 yeah
because now you don't get hit with the
bishop takes f2 knight takes e4 line i
have these two things confused if you
wanted to play this one this is also
very fine for white um
this is what hikaru plays this is what
some other like
chess streamers and youtubers recommend
um the thing with h3 here
there's a new move i discovered recently
g5
that i'll admit i haven't done too much
analysis on but it's
it leads to craziness
yeah i played a game like this in blitz
where i just accidentally stumbled upon
the perfect combination against the
i guess the uh
yeah staffer with knight c3h3 and then i
actually just played d3 i think i got a
pretty okay game with it but he did
three solid
yeah as long as you don't play bishop e2
because after bishop e2 there is a crazy
line queen d4
provoking castling
and then
g4
and then if takes or is h5 and black is
already preferable
so uh
i think it's worth sticking with the
line that we just showed
of course this is an alternative but you
should kind of know the difference
between knight c3 and d3 with d3 you
remain a bit more flexible with how you
develop your knight eventually
right right okay that sounds good okay
so knight c3 and d3 are both totally
acceptable here let's for now let's
stick with d3 i rather like it um the
positions i think
were not
entirely
poor
so here we go
c3 right
no wait
holy [ __ ] so this is where if you forget
you kind of have to rely on like your
understanding figuring things out
yeah
c3 makes sense because we want to push
d4 so c3
and this is where i have my takes e4
no
and then you have d takes e4 and bishop
takes f2 and everything goes downhill
oh my god not like this but like see c3
is still like better for white after
queen e2 but you don't want to mess with
it
so remember like c3 and h3 they're a bit
premature because they allow these
tricky tactics
so we just develop and then we protect
we protect the queen and give ourselves
the option of castle see this is the
part where we actually have to try to
like you can memorize moves or you can
also kind of like sometimes understand
understanding is way more important than
memorizing
yeah such a common mistake among like so
many especially beginner players they
just memorize but they don't understand
yeah no you need bishop to e2 not to
provoke h5 you need bishop e2 in order
to defend your queen and enable yourself
to castle so your king can also be safer
and your queen is also protected it's a
two in one kind of thing
the other way to understand this is by
asking the very simple question
what's the threat
right the threat is actually three-fold
here we can imagine there there's like a
three different moves black wants to
play
black either uh of course wants to play
knight g4 this is like the main threat
but there's also the idea of knight
takes e4 and bishop takes f2 with uh
these
like tactics with the d-file
so bishop e2 stops everything
there we go and this is this is
sometimes the best reply to like dealing
with gambits you just have to ask
yourself what's the threat how do i
effectively stop it
um so again we can continue
uh yeah now we can play c3 c3 could yeah
you want to play d4
so you're preparing to meet
knight g4 with
uh now we're ready to meet it with d4
awesome
yep
and then we can play g3
and then if queen of six then i castle
cool
well i will decide to play on
and
let me let me take on h2 let's see how
you deal with this
oh god okay
um
i have the evaluation bar on and the
evaluation bar says climbing
engine doesn't like this move but uh
sometimes this is what to do in stafford
i think i'll probably play g4 here
love it yeah and you're you're just
you're not letting me have any fun
if i play this you'll you'll hurt me
even more
yeah
yeah latex h2 is probably just not a
good move
yeah well that's the thing right a lot
of people way over so i always like to
emphasize that
there's a lot of threats and stuff and
like
attacking interest is very important by
the same time just remember if your
opponent overreaches and oversteps and
gives you too much material as long as
you don't get checkmated you'll probably
win
yep yeah that's that's a very fair way
of putting it yeah it's uh
a lot of people have the strategy they
want to go straight for the throat and
and try and destroy their opponent as
quickly as possible which i enjoy like
myself but uh
other strategy is just to be chill
take things when things are given to you
i like how eric has pretty much the
different playing style from his like
personality like totally different
there's eric you know wholesome sweet
streamer and then his chest style is
just like going all in
and meanwhile mine is more like uh
let me just wait forever until you make
a mistake yeah i feel like my my chest
style has been crafted by twitch chat
not sure if it's a good thing or a bad
thing but
uh over the the years of streaming
twitch chat has been
more and more incentivizing me to play
like aggressively dubiously and then
there
uh it just leads to more entertainment
so i've kind of developed this
this aggressive style as a streamer
i see i never really thought about it
that way because i have never ever
apart from the fact that i picked a
bullet for twitchette i've never rosen
stafford in rose and pogba
i want to play it so that's really
interesting you say that actually
yeah and
and then there's a side that people
don't really know about me because i'm
not too active in like serious
tournament play
but uh in classical tournaments i have a
very positional style i usually avoid
complications i don't play gambits over
the board really um
yeah well i haven't played too much like
the last couple of years but
my style otb is more reflective i guess
of my personality so oh
i see that makes a lot of sense yeah i
play otb and blitz the same way
unfortunately for my otp so
uh well actually i don't even play blitz
that much i just play bullet i play
bullet and oh tv pretty much the same
way which is also very much not good for
either style but that makes sense yeah
so and sometimes it helps to go outside
your comfort zone like if you're a more
positional player then you can learn a
lot by going for more tactical or
complicated positions
even if you'll lose more you'll uh
you'll improve overall as a player so
that's like i think for me one of the
the areas i need to work on otb is like
going for really complex positions and
then working on my calculation skills
so that would be a big step to making
the next jump to
whatever reading goals i'm trying for
what rating goals are you trying for
uh that's a good question my i mean i've
i've only played one event in the last
like two years which was vegas recently
oh right
like if you're gonna be another one in
december the there's a north american
open in december yeah
oh okay that's exciting yeah i'm still
trying to figure out my tournament
schedule but
it would be nice to get back to my feed
a peak like i hit
24.25 fee day back in 2015.
right my current fee day rating is 23 50
something so
okay 70 or so points off my peak
yeah i feel you i mean i peaked a long
time ago and i haven't really climbed
back or bothered to climb back as twitch
at likes to remind me
so
i feel you there i mean tournaments are
so hard to play when you already have
like a full you know streaming career
and you also do all everything
photography as well so
it's a lot to juggle yeah i mean it
helps to just enjoy like if you're going
to play a tournament just enjoy things
as much as possible
yeah and also the fact i guess for both
of us that we we're more focused on
streaming and content creation these
days
i think in some way that can help take
the pressure off tournament play and
maybe allow us to just play better given
that there's no no
oh
no i thought it would be easier to play
the world cup because i'm like i'm here
for content i'm here to like you know
just have a good time and i was like
man
chest
it's like i lost that that is not fun i
i really thought it would be better and
then it just wasn't better
so just finding balance is pretty hard
for me at least but maybe you have a
much healthier mindset
yeah i just kind of miss playing like
serious chess i mean it's stressful in
the moment but it can be rewarding like
if you play a fun game or
um sometimes like playing in
competitions even if i do badly
it forces me to study chess because
every time i play i'm like preparing
openings for opponents
so even if i lose games and lose rating
i'll actually improve
my overall play and expand my repertoire
so
um sometimes it just requires a
different mindset where you're just
trying to play to learn and grow as a
player
that's absolutely true i mean it's been
such a long time since i did anything
like that and it was really fun to do it
for the world cup and i also remember we
played like this one london at the world
cup well i mean not between
chat it wasn't the fact that aaron was
playing the female women's world cup
with me we were playing outside of the
actual events yeah i was uh not in the
playing room
yes he was not in the playing room but
there was that one london and i actually
wanted to
uh just quickly ju like juggle a few
bounce a few ideas of a few sure
definitely yeah like what do you really
dislike about the london that's why like
what do you hate most so
i mean i've seen this bishop f5 i've
played this bishop at f5 line which is
um
very symmetric right and i personally
don't like it i think hikaru also played
it in today's title tuesday but i
personally don't like it because it's so
drawish and i mean i obviously shouldn't
be um
well not that i shouldn't be but i don't
like josh positions that much i don't
want something that that's more dynamic
yeah i want spicy i like having a little
bit of spice in my life i mean
but i was impressed with your prep like
in our casual blitz game
i don't think i ever posted that one to
youtube because there was a copyright
song playing in the background oh no um
but we like we have the video i might
post it anyway
i posted it on mine uh for sure
yeah
i have that on my show i think it was
like i showed everyone how to play
london but yeah that was a fun one i
think it went like this
it was probably something a lot like
this
uh you played uh you you didn't play c5
so soon you played bishop d6 95 yeah
i think you were following your prep for
your first round opponent in in world
cup
um it was knight d2 c5
uh and then you played this knight e4
move mm-hmm i played queen c2 and then
then you were very well prepared with
cd4 which not too many players know
and then i ended up blundering like
really soon
um i think i'm supposed to take on cease
i i think i just took back and then you
played f6
yep i remember you playing knight takes
c6 i took on f4 and you played knight
before and i actually had eight five and
you can trap my knight yeah like i took
so long and then
yeah i'll have to you were distracting
me yes
yeah i mean this was one of those games
where it was like
it's it's just like what
i mean obviously you don't have to play
exactly theory this is another worry
like when i when i study theory and when
i play three my opponent might not know
that he's supposed to play siri too and
then he strays off of the you know the
the beat and chorus and i'm like what
the [ __ ]
my dude
help
so this is why understanding
is just more important than memorizing
lines because if you understand like
ideas and the poem deviates then you'll
still have some grasp of what the
relevant ideas are in the position
and uh
it's part of chess any every chess game
there's going to be some point where you
leave your comfort zone or leave opening
theory and you'll be on your own and you
just have to prepare yourself for those
situations
yeah
i mean this is the part where i think
after i was looking at i played some
other games using this line and i think
castle was probably one of the other
things i was looking at where i just
don't have this option of c takes d4
um
and it just gets and then i trust music
yeah
um
yeah this is where like i guess the
engine will suggest i mean i i assume uh
f6 is a idea
that's true
well f6 knight takes c6
b take bishop takes f4 he takes f4 but b
takes c6 and then i mean that pawn is
just not a worry for why right like
actually surprisingly having that double
pawn is not usually that big of a worry
for white because you just permanently
stop black from pushing up the e5 pawn
yeah i actually don't really know the
london for i've only ever played it as
black so all my assumptions
about white's positional gameplay comes
from me playing it as black i will also
say this is a kind of a new line for me
the um this like early 95 move
because usually i don't play this move
order like
for the first many years of me playing
london i play bishop g3 which is just
another line like right to look into i
guess you have to be prepared as black
played the exact well this is me
revealing all my preparation now but i
play the exact same way i just go castle
okay let's see
okay
okay
ah so queen c7 yeah so this is a very
trendy line these days
idea knight bb7 and e5
um
yeah objectively like black can can
equalize without too much trouble
um
i have my own kind of sideline that i
play against this is to
go for this e4 move
oh people have been playing this against
me i find it really annoying i hate it
when op when the center is not closed i
have this like i'm a spanish player so i
always like it if my center is like
perfectly locked
center interesting yeah i like those
positions a lot here i actually have no
idea what to do
yeah don't play knight c6 this is one of
the main traps after knight b3 you're
losing uh materials oh shoot
so i'll save you from future trauma
uh knight g7 i think rookie eight
i'll admit it's uh like i don't remember
so much specific preparation but
um
as far as i
recall there's some idea to play e5
you may be right
d takes e4 i'm guessing
it's probably my only option yeah and
then in this position
uh i like to take with
the bishop
that takes e4 might be slightly better
oh there's the idea if it takes we we
fork
we fork
i like this because sometimes people
pre-move they takes e4 is black in this
position
do you do you like
train openings well i mean actually i
guess you don't have to tell me this
because i'm i'm happy to share secrets
like oh okay i'm not super serious and
like trying to get to the next level and
keep everything hidden so
yeah okay i mean i i usually have never
liked that it's just i'm very well aware
that you know you're playing tournaments
and stuff and usually when i play
tournaments i hop on to like five
different alts accounts and i never play
any games on stream and yeah anyways i
get super serious about it so i just
don't know how serious you are and so i
don't want to like ask you for opening
stuff and it turns out to be something
you actually end up playing so i just
want to
uh check in with you on that yeah my
philosophy is that if if i share like my
own prep out there
people might prepare against it but it
will motivate me to prepare even deeper
against other people's prep so
it allows me to learn more and um
oh
the other thing is that i play a bunch
of different stuff like i can play
london i can play e4 i can play c4
so people kind of have to look at a lot
of lines if they want to prepare against
me
uh really for each color
so yeah feel free like i'm happy to
share secrets
okay yeah no i mean the london is really
interesting because i play this line but
i i actually have been running to this
line now that we actually talk about
because i have this issue where when you
plan an opening on stream during blitz
or whatever bullet right you just forget
the opening like instantly and then you
just you're like the next time you see
it like oh you had to look at this line
and then you keep doing that i keep
never ever ever looking at any of the
openings so
like i remember now i have a lot of
issues in london like specifically this
one for example
um which is just very annoying i just
don't know what to do here apparently
the engine says bishop takes g3 but i
don't see a plan after that
yeah you kind of have to complete
development um
i mean it might be worth like if you're
not enjoying these positions because the
center is opening up and
this bishop i mean it's subjectively
fine you just have to maybe expand on
the ideas further like if you're getting
these structures to
to learn it even deeper
um but i mean there's so many things you
can play against london
especially if you're playing a move
order
like from this move order there's
there's so many different ways black can
can fight the london
i think you briefly asked me like what i
i dislike the most about playing the
london and one of the more annoying
lines is uh is pawn c5
oh really okay
where
i'll play e3
knight c6
uh-huh and now
of course okay if you're playing black
here you you're gonna have to learn like
a few of the tricky deviations
the trendy move these days is knight b
d2
okay but against a lot of like if you
play online against a lot of players
people will play c3
and this is already preferable for black
after queen beast oh with the queen b6
okay you're maybe familiar with this
line
i am very familiar with this from
trompowsky ah okay yeah a similar idea
yeah okay idea queen b3 c4 if takes it's
good structure for black
if queen c2 you have bishop f5
right this bishop f5 move is very
interesting
i like it and yeah of course the queen
can't take because we win material and
if queen c1
you can choose between e6 or the move i
like is knight h5 and
uh you get the bishop hair just better
position for black
absolutely this is one of those lines
that so the thing that chess
sorry chat trendy equals good and trendy
typically means not just good it means
that it's like topical as of this moment
so there's like trends in chess
like if carlson will play one line at
some point then everybody will want to
play that line or like you know
somebody like kasparov or not well
because far not so much now but a lot of
the top grand monsters they play on you
like giri or something everybody will
want to play that one line
so yep and then it's usually the top
like super gm setting the trends for the
rest of us like mere mortals
um but yeah like recently at very high
level this uh this london knight bd2
has been like very trendy especially in
like rapid and blitz
and if you want to really try and
just out prepare white in the london
it requires a ton of like study and
knowledge and um it might not be
the most like practical approach for you
but yeah at like a very high level queen
v6 is one of the the most testing lines
against london even
okay
i
yeah i mean i don't know if i want to
just play like my e6 bishop d6 stuff
and just keep playing that if i want to
actually like fully commit to play like
queen b6 or something like that because
you know that is a lot of theory right
and all that but it looks fun to test
out
yeah if you play queen b6 you're
basically asking for a theoretical
battle difference here is okay white
doesn't have queen b3 but there's dc5
and it gets into like this really messy
gambit type position
um which
it's good to be aware of but uh
it's the type of thing like okay if
you're like a super pro player it's
worth like ex putting the hours but
um if you want a more simple line here
there are different lines to choose from
um very popular these days is just to
take on d4
relieve the tension
and then put your bishop on f5 or g4
and bishop f5 is very standard
and then you can get kind of a very
solid like reverse um
[Music]
you know reverse like queen's gambit
exchange it's like so-called carl's bad
structure
oh yes the uh e63 structures yep yeah
and most times light does play c3 you
play e6
and you're ready to play bishop d6 and
especially if you're playing a lot of
blitz and bullet online this i think is
like a bit easier to internalize and
there's less trickiness white can try
yeah i like this because i think today i
was looking at a a game that he car
would play with like bishop f5 out but
when they took on d4 it was uh with pawn
on e3 instead of
so it would be like this pawn structure
but f3 e3 and d4 which is
so much more symmetrical than this
cospot structure right like it's just
it's just
unplayable for a win or anything like
that so i definitely like it when the
pawn structures are not symmetrical oh
yeah for sure there's more gameplay and
if you're playing this line against like
a little red player who's trying to just
be solid against you
and maybe play for a draw or just play
to get a drier position
yeah there's a lot of dynamic things
that can happen
of course even if you trade bishops
once you complete development you have
the minority attack potential
you have just very nice piece harmony
there's also a potential gambit line
here
if white plays one of the main moves
queen b3
you can gambit the b7 pawn
with bishop d6
okay this is a line i'd probably
recommend just
knowing
and if you just know the basics you can
get like interesting positions as takes
uh takes takes and king f8
and you've lost a pawn but you have the
bishop hair white's queen is a bit
deep in black's territory the king is
still in the center there's some cool
ideas with the kingside pawn storm
i took some time like just studying this
as black and
played this in a few blitz games
so this is if you wanted to like peel
another layer
and
uh
and expand upon okay like here's my
solid setup but if you want to learn
something more specific you can kind of
learn deeper into this gamut line and
maybe uh out prepare even strong players
you definitely like the gambit lines i i
respect that so this is a way so there's
uh when we say gambit there's different
kind of tiers of gambits
there's really uh like dubious gambits
which are directly like maybe not so
good but still super trappy
yeah
but then there's also just
variations where you sack a pawn
and you get a different type of
advantage
and you get adequate compensation
basically so here
this is computer approved
like if you turn on the engine it will
initially prefer white
uh but then
if you start digging deeper and maybe
use an engine with more depth
uh
and also like look at the not only rely
on the engine but like look at the
databases
you'll you'll see that black scores
pretty well here
got it yeah i mean i can definitely see
the compensation appeal of this position
i am just very very bad at gambiting i
am extremely awful at like being okay
with losing material in exchange for
something or the potential to get it
back later it's just a very like it's
just like a personal kind of thing it's
really got nothing to do with the actual
position this is totally fine i can see
that gotcha
and yeah sometimes you just want to
choose openings that more align with
your style like if you want to just
not go into gambit sharp positions where
you're down material and have to prove
compensation
like here queen c8 is a completely
acceptable move
it was actually i think the main line
even though bishop d6 was more trendy
recently but uh yeah yeah here you just
kind of
just defend right yeah
man
so many options in japanese
and every so many people and then you
always have to make this little gap
gamble like does my opponent know it all
or do i know him more than my opponent
yeah eventually like as long as you're
not blundering anything too severe
you and your opponent will be on your
own and then you don't have to worry
about like super deep preparation but
i know it's scary when the opponent is
like very deeply prepared in
uh in sharp lines but
in a quieter position it's it's more
about what will
unfold in the middle game and end game
[Music]
yeah absolutely i mean
all of these things guys we're only
going to like move eight or ten
usually these lines go on like we're not
in lines but we usually get the ideas
all the way until like move 20
and sometimes not even reaching move 20
is enough you have to know all the
middle game plans as well for off to
move 20. so you basically have the first
30 moves off the game more or less like
structured out at least that's how i
used to do well that's how i did my
world cup it depends on the opening like
if you're playing like najdorf grunfell
there's like mainline cecilians
yeah that's why like i
i've enjoyed playing offbeat lines where
i can pretty much guarantee my opponent
won't be super well prepared and i can
be more prepared even if it's maybe
objectively worse
it still like has a surprise value
yeah i
i definitely think that like what are
some of the surprise openings you use
for your over the board games like do
you do you just play like do you like
kind of default to like normal-ish kind
of stuff or do you still prepare like
specific lines like but by this i mean
for example for the world for the world
cup i prepared
e4
uh
c5 i'm white i always play the open
sicilian but for this one game i
prepared the close sicilian because uh
based on what she plays
so i mean more like that i i love
playing knight c3 because there's a lot
of like move order tricks
uh for white where like you can you can
start with close sicilian and then
transpose into open sicilian
yeah i'm trying to think back like my
most recent tournament in vegas where i
like i prepared for every opponent
before i play them
usually
i'll find my opponent's online account
scour through their on or their their
online repertoire or they're like
tournament repertoire if they have games
in the database
and then
most of my preparation is specific to
whatever opponent i'm i'm playing
yeah that makes sense that's exactly how
i do it right i can give you an example
like i played uh rochelle wu in vegas
and
i don't know if you know rochelle wu one
of the top uh like young
young players in the us
okay i'm not sure okay she's like rated
2 300 but type of player who has like a
very consistent rapper tour like plays
nardorf as black
uh like a loyal sicilian player
so there is a line i prepared um
after pawn d6
is to play pawn d4
got it and this is another like trendy
thing among like super gm level like
theory's still developing
but to get a position after takes takes
i don't think she played knight c6 but
the the overall point is to put the
queen back on d2
and then go for the fiance and just get
a
a structure that black is not used to
playing against
uh you know what i'm gonna steal this
one i'm gonna steal it it's a nice one
and it's something that you don't have
to play every time but you can play
against the right player to try and
throw them off
it's very similar to the one i play
against knight to c6 where uh after
bishop b5 i don't know if you play this
one oh so this one i uh yeah i went
through a phase
actually more recently i've been looking
at knight f3 i i also used to play
bishop c4
oh i've never played bishop c4 this i
mean i very specifically prepared this
for the world cup so i only bothered
learning this one line and i was like
this is the only thing i'm going to play
um but it's really interesting because
at some point
black goes like g6 right and then
there's this really interesting idea of
work b1 and b4 ids or b3 and b2 so you
also go for van ghetto so anyways that's
why this one reminded me a lot of that
because it's like a fianchetto but in a
totally different position so
yeah it's like one way to kind of stray
away from theory i think carlson is the
one who innovated this uh
this b3 line and it got really hot for a
while
yeah
it's apparently trendy right now which
means everybody's gonna know how to play
against it
yeah but even even if like opponents are
like
even expecting it you can still get a
playable position with like very rich
ideas that can still align with your
style
of course yeah
i fully agree with that i mean i just
like
well i definitely prefer it if we can
avoid the whole opening theory match
thingy
but so you're you'd prefer more like
going to 960
uh
you just avoid
entirely
i usually lose in the theory battle with
people just because i don't spend as
much time as they do
so i definitely want to just play middle
games but i i'm also very consciously
aware that hey that's just not what
where chess is right now like
uh it's not like how i could play it 10
years ago
for example right so yeah i mean you can
still try and find like kind of pet
lines where you don't need to know too
much theory that might be a bit more
offbeat
that can allow you to
just know less and then focus on just
playing chess can also help to maybe
broaden your aperture to have a few
things to choose between
which is
yeah like one of the main ways i
surprise people is just like choosing
between e4 d4 c4 even sometimes knight
f3
and uh if you play them all they will be
confused
yeah like sometimes if someone let's say
they play the nimzo indian
which is like classically e6 bishop b4
against knight c3 then i'll play an
english move order where if they play
knight f6
and e6
i don't have to play d4 but i can play
e4
and this is a completely different
opening this is called the floor
mechanism
i see i see i see
okay so you're just being okay well i
mean that just means your knowledge like
your base knowledge of openings is just
so wide because you're able to like
conveniently transposed between all
these things meanwhile i just play like
the spanish or the sicilian those are
like my two openings gotcha yeah so
i mean for me i've i've put in like a
lot of time just like i've gone through
different phases of like only playing
english only playing london
um but even if you're like let's say a
hardcore spanish player
you can still maybe
deviate within the spanish
okay uh
like as white if you're playing let's
say this
this bishop e7 or playing against this
bishop e7 i assume you just play main
line right i just play main lines yeah
everything's at berlin i refuse to play
berlin so if they play the berlin i just
go d3 okay that's a respectable approach
um
so here i'm trying to remember spanish
mainline do you play c3 here i play h3
to count well counter the wrong word but
avoid the marshall gotcha accurate yes
so i can give you just a surprise
opening let's say i'm preparing for
someone
that plays a marshall as black and
enters this position
uh the move i like to play is d4
oh
yeah i
beat them to the the chase um yes
and
the then there's some like there's some
cool lions like
some players will play knight takes d4
hoping that after the trade
black is winning a piece
however
we don't go into this because this this
is terrible right
uh instead
after knight takes d4 there's crazy move
bishop takes
f7 oh
oh wow and knight takes e5 is coming
like raqir takes and
uh it's easy for black to like stumble
into some potential traps if they're not
prepared
i want to play this so bad i am i am so
ready to play this line now so this this
is just a small bit of inspiration but
this is usually how i pick up over
things like i'll see a line like this
uh-huh um like the first time i i
discovered this line i had the black
side of this position
oh i see it was just an online game and
i played 96
my opponent took took played e5 here i
lost my rook
and then oh no i then i was inspired to
play it for whites
i respect that so you're using the
things that you got stabbed with
now to stab other people
understood
that is pretty cool yeah it's cool to
like see what weapons people have and
then kind of use them for yourself
makes sense makes sense uh then there's
another kind of cool line if uh like the
main move here is g6
i should note if pawn takes pawn you
have this move
right
it's a gambit style position but
you control a lot of space
and main line is d6 and then you can
play c3
and this goes into like uh
it's called the yates variation of the
spanish where you didn't play h3 so
you're allowing bishop g4
but then bishop e3 it leads to like some
uh dynamic lines
variation is white actually
but uh
yeah this would be something i could
definitely play in blitz and maybe
incorporate as a surprise line in
spanish because i've been playing for 18
years i'm always looking for new lines
to play in spanish as both black and
white definitely and then that'll kind
of expand your appreciation for the
opening and it will make you more
difficult to prepare against too if
let's say you're capable of playing
mainline or yates variation or maybe
some other sidelines
yep
absolutely i mean this is a great great
little piece of knowledge you have man
your your knowledge of openings is just
really fun to poke at i'm sorry i'm just
very amused like it's just great i oh
thank you i love discussions like this
yeah really that's awesome i've never i
don't know did you have well i guess you
kind of live in like a chess environment
but did did you like have people to like
discuss openings and stuff with when you
were
playing journalism
yeah well i
i went to i attended webster university
for a couple years
and then before that another college
where i i was always kind of part of a
college chess team
so
my two years at webster like my coach
was susan polgar
i was training with a bunch of gms
including
ray robson chessweed
uh shimanov uh laquan liam so a lot of
people just bouncing off ideas and
you just pick up a lot of ideas from
studying with a team
of course
i'm very well i won't say i'm jealous
because i definitely don't want to do
that currently i'm already very much
over over like well with chess but i
think it would have been amazing if i
had something like that when i was a
little bit younger where it's like yeah
having getting to bounce all these ideas
instead of like having a coach tell me
what to do would have been so much more
beneficial for my creativity in chess
because otherwise like you know you're
it sounds like you've spent a lot of
time investing and finding what you
actually enjoy i just kind of got told
what to do
yeah it helps to like have some like
spark of passion or motivation
where you see like a cool trap and then
you just want to expand further and
develop a whole repertoire around a
certain line
even like i'll pick up ideas from
various places like uh
sometimes just following current games
actually the reason why i picked up this
variation specifically
i i showed you like that first trap but
then there's another trap
which happens let's see if i can
remember it
it happens after the
yeah in this this position
uh takes takes
d5 it's like one of the main lines
e5 here
and it came
i i discovered it
by sitting next to jeffrey zhang and
andrew ting
at the 2015 world or 2015 philly open
uh-huh and
jeffrey played white he won in like
within 20-25 moves
and he played this really like
it was almost a novelty there was only
like one game in it prior
uh the novelty came in this position he
played queen c3
and uh
i was sitting next to the game and then
i think andrew was thinking for like
over 20 minutes
and uh then after the game i like looked
this up and i saw like oh the engine
approves it and black is under a lot of
pressure and it's complicated and then
then the following year i played the
same move against christian gorilla in
vegas
oh my god let's go i like it's cool to
like see someone's like rare idea and
then use it against someone else uh yeah
sometime later so
like stuff like this it um it keeps a
passion and
sometimes when chess gets boring for me
then i'll i'll try and look look into
more
interesting and uh tricky openings
i like to hear that that's really good
so that's kind of like how you keep
yourself invested
what would be like a gambit
recommendation for somebody who's
incredibly new to gambits like not just
necessarily for me but for like
twitch chat like just uh average uh
um
yeah like the what are like the og
gambits i mean there's england gambit
which is
um i mean very popular these days among
like the the sub 1500 players even
higher level too
um
there is
you know i'll just try and rattle off a
few there's king's gambit
oh the vienna gambit right
that's a more like controlled yeah
that's like less risky um and also like
probably no idea how to play against the
vienna gambit as black it is bad do you
play e5 as black yeah oh i didn't know
that i think maybe i didn't know that
but i play e5 and c5 so it's a bit like
a coin flip whatever so i i spent a ton
of time researching this is black and
just in preparation for levy
right because you played a match against
levy recently also in person yes i
remember yeah all like we've had our our
fair share of battles but d5 is the
go-to move
and then takes takes
uh
he usually likes to play queen f3 and
then f5 is like the the way to deal with
this but it still requires some
knowledge
yeah all right so
i will take a look at this actually so
knight c3 f6 f4 d5
okay
um that's just scraping the surface but
um
if you know to enter this it's already
like
preferable for black
yeah i love how white's best move after
f5 is rook b1
that's very funny too wait engine's
giving rook b1
yeah bishop e2 rick b1
on depth only 16 but i'll run it through
lila later ah okay
yeah i think most games go like d3
there's some main line take 6 d4 but uh
yeah maybe in in cases where the b file
opens uh yeah it makes sense
okay
um
yeah other gambits like there's danish
gambit
there's evan's gambit
there's a lot of like if you play e4 you
can play gambits against most of the
uh defenses from black
like if uh if c5 there's smith more
gambit or wing gambit that
oh i hate gambits
[Music]
my biggest biggest fear my biggest
weakness are gambits yeah against smith
mora
um
there's this line that i've enjoyed
playing
like uh it's called the siberian trap
oh
have you heard of this bishop b4 line
oh bishop b42 i've heard is uh
is quite tricky
uh yeah
and then there's just like d5 ideas at
some point but i still haven't figured
that line out either
all of these are like things that i'm
trying to figure out yeah it takes time
just to like
look into the lines and
um yeah you just have to to spend some
time to
to know the moves this is a siberian
trap knight g4
if white plays h3
looks very normal then there's knight d4
winning on the spot
um nice kind of tactical harmony
with the queen and the knights
those look very good indeed
but yeah like with yeah with with all
the gambits you kind of have to be aware
of which ones can be played against your
repertoire and then
be ready for them and
sometimes if you struggle against a
certain gambit you can play it for the
other side and then see
see how people deal with it
absolutely
i i definitely need to do a little bit
of both because otherwise it's just like
i don't know what i'm doing i need to i
need to play a little bit of gambits
myself to see what what's really gonna
yeah
just to see how i can counter them also
like to get myself a little bit more
comfortable with them so many reasons to
play a little bit more gambits
definitely yeah it teaches you just a
different style of chess where like one
side
socks material goes for counter play
things get messy
yeah it can make life more spicy
there's one
there is like on the topic of gambits
it's like the coolest opening trap
maybe i've ever seen in my life
uh but it's like a super rare one that i
discovered recently
and
i spent most of the day yesterday like
pre-recording a youtube video about this
gambit oh but it's called the o'sullivan
gambit
oh
sullivan
it starts with
d4 or starts with an alkyne e5 d4
so most common moves for white
and then from this position black plays
b5
oh
i feel i feel a little bit wrong showing
to showing this to you before i'm
actually playing it against you
but
it's okay we already know that we're
gonna have another match right
yes yes
and also guys make sure you're following
um eric's youtube channel for all of
these amazing campet things
like the b5 i don't know i've never seen
this before so the point okay
i think i'll just show you the the
really cool trap because it's it's
pretty stunning
most people take
like just looks like a free pawn
and then black will play c5
threatening queen a5
so it's very easy for white to just miss
us
like if knight f3 queen a5 and
double attack and knight c3 we take
so the cool trap happens after pawn c4
looks fine for white hitting the knight
surprising move pawn takes d4
now if white takes a knight we have
queen a5 again
so
actually like starting with c4 and going
into this position
all of the most played moves for white
will be the moves that kind of walk into
the eventual trap
so most common moves queen takes d4
uh still looks good for white
we play knight b4
okay threatening triple fork
it doesn't seem like black should be
doing much damage like there's only one
piece developed
and we've gambit of the pawn
[Music]
most people play knight a3 just
defending
and now queen a5
uh-huh
threatening the
discover triple fork
okay so as white what you do
bishop oh wait no bishop d2 is
what's wrong bishop d2 so bishop d2 most
played move yeah looks safe
black to move oh queen takes a3 knight
c2 knight takes d4 yeah queen a3 so when
we played 25 like this was also a threat
ah
but then it gets better
so much stuff going on
yeah
so of course it takes we went back the
queen box off the piece
yep
so
why we'll play this move
queen e4 hitting the rook our queen's
still hanging
[Music]
we can take on b2
yeah
now rook b1
the queen hitting the rook
oh queen digs e5 with 93.
wow you found that quickly a very it's a
it's a fork it's a fork we are looking
for the horse here
yeah queen e5
and
yeah so our queen
went from a5 to a3 to b2
sacrificed itself twice but
it's always like the tactics are always
working for black
and how did you find this one
this one was
i don't know i think it was like some
random instagram dm
like you know how on instagram people
send you dms but they get into sent into
like the other like the random folder
but i looked at it and
um then i just forgot about it but i
remember the line you openings on
instagram dms
yeah it's kind of the
the nature of what people uh
it's not the worst thing in the world
wait people slide into your dms with
openings i'll get a decent amount of
like oh hey i i found like a cool
opening trap and usually it's just like
their opponent blundering on move five
but sometimes it's actually pretty cool
[Music]
why is that all so wholesome
yeah i mean it's it's probably like a
small percentage of my overall dm's
it's one of the more wholesome types of
dms
that's amazing no i'm glad you have that
interaction on instagram
yeah and i tried to do research on like
the the name but i i couldn't find like
who is o sullivan
and like there's almost no
content
about this opening online and it's such
a cool trap and there's other traps that
exist so
[Music]
uh
so yeah but this is like your this is
this is your baby now i guess apparently
where whoever o'sullivan was is i guess
this is not yours but now now i'm
sharing the baby so we can all
enjoy the
the beauty of the baby together i guess